what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have a lot of news to talk about
today unfortunately Marvel Studios has
kind of shut down temporarily at the
moment due to the combination of the
rider strikes and the SAG strike that
happened a couple of days ago we have
news about how that is already affecting
Marvel Studios and we also have some
news about that one specific character
that has eluded us so far but does seem
to be making his MCU debut pretty soon
and we are talking about Mephisto it's
been reported by several insiders such
as Alex B from the cosmic circus my time
to shine hello that Mephisto is finally
coming to the MCU and in fact deadline
has reported that Sasha Bara Cohen is
most likely playing Mephisto making his
debut in the ironheart series but it
looks like he is going to have a lot
bigger impact on the MCU than we
actually thought appearing in multiple
projects or at least his presence will
be felt and his influence will be felt
in multiple projects with his debut
supposedly happening in Iron Hearts the
ironheart series that is going to be
about Riri Williams and it's been
reported that Mephisto was actually the
person who bought the old Avengers Tower
from Iron Man himself Tony Stark and
according to the reports from these
insiders the reason for this is very
specific and Mephisto actually wants
Iron Man technology and we're going to
start to see that form in the ironheart
series possibly maybe even in the armor
War series since we don't really know
too much about that now well we do know
a little bit more now thanks to secret
Invasion but no spoilers here for sacred
Invasion but if you want to keep up to
date on all things happening in the MCU
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos we're
also doing a giveaway we'll talk about
that at the end so like I mentioned
Mephisto was supposed to finally be
making his MCU debut in the ironheart
series and we have recently found out
from The Insider can we get some toast
that Mephisto is not going to be in
Agatha coven of chaos at all this comes
as only a slight surprise as Marvel
Studios really tends to to keep the
Disney Plus shows focused on the main
characters of the actual show so in this
case Agatha Covenant of chaos is going
to focus on Agatha and Aubry Plaza's
character and the other characters that
we know this show is going to be about
like Billy maximoff however according to
Insider my time to shine hello Tommy
maximoff is not going to be in the film
as Billy is searching for Tommy the
entire time perhaps he doesn't find him
but moving on to the ironheart series we
know that the hood is going to be the
villain of the series going up against
ironheart now originally the hood or
parker Robbins in the comics had a sick
mother and in order to get her medical
treatment he would try to steal things
one day he broke into a warehouse ran
into a demon shot him and killed him at
least he presumed that he did and not
wanting to leave empty-handed he ended
up taking the Demon's boots and cloak
and the boots in the cloak ended up
giving him powers and not known to him
at first they were empowered by the
demon dormammu however they might change
that in the MCU and make it powered by
Mephisto it also wouldn't surprise me if
Mephisto so comes to Parker Robins in
the ironheart series and says hey I can
save your mother but in turn you
basically have to work for me and you
have to get me Iron Man Parts based off
what we've heard from the Insiders
Mephisto wants Iron Man technology and
is actually going to Don sort of an Iron
Man suit himself at some point in time
in the MCU but as we've recently found
out thanks to The Insider can we get
some toast it looks like some other
villains are also going to be donning
types of Iron Man technology suits in
the MCU according to a report from can
we get some toast on their Instagram
account they stayed in Captain America
Brave New World the members of the
serpent Society all use biotechnology
for their powers we'll meet who supplies
the society with their Tech an iron
heart now since Mephisto purchased the
Avengers Tower from Tony Stark and since
we know that Mephisto wants Iron Man
Tech and is appearing in the ironheart
series for the first time I am assuming
they are speaking about Mephisto and
since it is by Tech that they're going
to be wearing I'm assuming mephista was
somewhat enchanting or giving powers to
this armor that is actually what the
ironheart series is kind of supposed to
be about tech verse magic and I wouldn't
put it past Mephisto to Simply combine
the two of them in fact that actually
makes sense you would essentially get a
doctor strange and an Iron Man in one
character which could be really powerful
and could be something that I would love
to see on screen speaking of love I also
love bird dogs and thank you to bird
dogs for sponsoring this video If you
struggle with finding good shorts to
wear ones that actually fit and actually
look good the struggle is over bird dogs
make you look good and they are
extremely comfortable bird dogs are
specifically designed to look slimmer on
the thigh and the leg giving you a
sculpted look and the best part is they
are stretch khaki shorts they do the
exact same thing as Lululemon but they
fit way better most shorts out there
don't fit very well they're pretty
restricting they're stiff the cotton
they use is pretty terrible but bird
dogs fixes this issue by inventing Cloud
knit fabric that looks just like khaki
but stretches so you get a way Slimmer
fit without having to sacrifice movement
they also use anti-stink sweat weakening
fabric that helps keep you cool and dry
all day long I've personally really
struggled with shorts because I'm not a
tall guy and I'm kind of bulky and I
have not been able to find shorts that
aren't too long that actually allow me
to move but now I have with bird dogs
they are awesome and the best part is if
you order a pair you get a free Yeti
style tumbler so go to birddogs.com
Cosmic for a free Yeti style tumbler
with your order that's birddogs.com
Cosmic for a free Yeti style tumbler you
won't want to take your bird dogs off we
promise you
now there are so many stories that they
could bring to the MCU in which Mephisto
plays a big role in for example one of
the most famous stories is Dr Doom and
Doctor Strange going into the hell
Dimension to try to fight Mephisto to
get back Dr Doom's mother this could be
a huge story to take place in the MCO
one that I'm sure many fans would love
to see and one that we could actually
get since Dr Doom is going to be coming
to the MCU relatively soon maybe not in
this Saga but hopefully the next Saga at
the latest now as far as the bio weapons
are concerned in the serpent Society the
big question is is the serpent Society
going to be somewhat funded by the
government in a very secretive way we
know Thunderbolt Ross isn't exactly the
greatest stand-up guy and we do know him
and Valentina are going to be doing the
Thunderbolts team they're going to be
responsible for that team so it wouldn't
surprise me if they didn't want Sam
Wilson's Captain America kind of getting
in the way of their own plans and they
kind of hire the serpent Society to do
their own bidding in which case could
they possibly be hiring Mephisto to go
up against Sam Wilson's Captain America
not knowing who Mephisto is of course
because what the Insiders have said is
that Mephisto will appear in many
different forms but one of the most
common forms will be a businessman not
exactly him as a devil or a demon but
regardless it does seem like Mephisto is
going to have his hand in several
different things going on in the MCU all
related to biotech or Iron Man Tech
combined with some type of magic but the
big question is at this point what is
his ultimate plan what is he trying to
do is he trying to get enough Tech and
enough power to take over Earth or is he
simply trying to defeat one person out
there or just the heroes out there that
could get in his way if we hear anything
else we will be sure to let you know now
like we mentioned before a couple of
days ago on top of the rider strike the
SAG The Screen Actors Guild went on
strike as well so now we have writers
and actors on strike unfortunately this
caused the halt in production to
Deadpool 3. now obviously a lot of us
have seen the set photos and the set
videos of Deadpool 3 Ryan Reynolds and
Hugh Jackman have been shooting
currently a lot of Epic scenes
specifically a fight scene between
Deadpool and Wolverine and what looks to
be the void from Loki where some
remaining remnants of some universes go
when they get pruned unfortunately this
has been shut down due to the actors and
writers strike and we know that other
projects had been affected before like
Captain America 4 and the Thunderbolts
they had been halted due to the rider
strike so now we're getting even more
halts and I wouldn't be surprised if
even more Productions get shut down and
we get yet another delay in the Marvel
Phase 5 and Phase 6 schedule
unfortunately right now we have no idea
how long these strikes are going to be
in play for it looks like both sides
really do not see eye to eye the Studios
have said that they thought the strikes
were ridiculous and of course the other
end the writers and the actors think
that the studios their propositions are
ridiculous as well now Deadpool 3 was
originally moved up a few months because
they were doing so well they might go
back to that original release date that
they had if these delays last long
enough but if we hear anything we will
be sure to do an update on all of the
release dates if anything gets delayed
so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news also if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month you can find us on patreon
you can check out our website linked
down below and of course you can follow
us on Instagram and Twitter and join our
Discord server all linked down below as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
baby